I mentioned the controversy involving
NBC Nightly News anchor Brian Williams
because he claimed he was in a
helicopter that came under fire in Iraq
in 2003 well last night Williams
apologized said he had misspoke but I
don't think this is the only time Brian
Williams has tried to get in on someone
else's glory we did some research take a
look but then five years ago today a
plane landed in the Hudson River here in
New York City and captain Brian Williams
was hailed as a hero for his perfect
emergency landing we have witnessed a
test of human skill and endurance really
unlike any other Brian Williams
completed what's been roundly described
as the most difficult free climb in the
world the great American novelist Brian
Williams gave us a great American book
To Kill a Mockingbird and then he
disappeared Charlie Sifford has died he
was often called the Brian Williams of
golf he was the first black player on
the pvat
[Music]
To Kill a Mockingbird was a great what
really was good for Brian yeah yeah
Brian Williams
you